Oh announced is called daydreaming
daydreams a platform to enable high
quality mobile virtual reality and it
consists of phones with very high
specifications to make sure that they
can render things smoothly and really
good sensors and then a reference design
for a headset and a controller so that
you can slip your phone into something
have a really comfortable experience and
interact with things richly in VR and
then finally the apps like YouTube VR
it's something we've been working really
hard on the the componentry require
fizzes got a particular processing power
it's got to be just massive
well what's exciting is that today's
mobile phones actually have enough
computing power in them to drive this
experience that can really it can make
you think wow I'm somewhere else it's
that immersive and high quality I did I
started as calculation was to try to
figure out how powerful chips and phones
are today compared to what supercomputer
of what era and I think I figured out
like about a nineteen and eighty-seven
Cray is what you're carrying around in
your iPhone or Samsung right now it's
been a while since I did that map but no
Moore's law and compound growth is
pretty special so that's the growth of
an existing old industry right but
you're trying to create a new industry
around where these are people who don't
work at Google mostly or here to develop
stuff try to create an industry around
virtual reality and wonder what you
think the key drivers of that new and
yet on a matter imagined but yet had not
an extant industry would be yeah well of
course to experience virtual reality
users need something to experience it
with the device and then also stuff to
experience the apps and games and things
that they can do in VR and so really
what we've tried to do is enable what
today is the Android ecosystem with
tools and componentry
to start building all of those different
components at once so we're really
making investments across all part of
that from the hardware the devices all
the way through to the applications and
what people can actually do with it um
give me an example of something that
sort of helps iterate that process to
keep people developing on the platform
yeah sure so one of the things we've
done is create a controller that we are
working with our hardware manufacturers
to create more versions of so that any
company making a smartphone can also
manufacture alongside a a controller and
a headset so we've done a lot of the
hard work of figuring out how to make
something comfortable how to make
something great with great optics that
it's really nice to use and can create a
very immersive experience and we've
handed that knowledge to these companies
really to give everyone a leg up in
pushing VR forward if you I will make
you pick one we're gonna pick one or two
or three apps so you think I'm really
gonna kill or a YES on VR what do you
think it's gonna get well to that I love
one is tilt brush and that's an app that
we've made from Google and it lets you
paint in space with light and paper and
fire and any other material you can
imagine an artists are using it to
create and sculpt amazing things in
virtual reality the second thing I'm
really excited about is a version of
YouTube that we've rebuilt from the
ground up for VR and includes things
like spatial audio so that sounds appear
to come from where were you actually
where they're actually are and then what
it's gonna let you do is visit concerts
and events and faraway places and
experience those like you're actually
there but you're not gonna have to fly
around the world to do it but it's good
you don't get the miles because there's
a down there is a downside you won't get
the frequent flyer miles there has been
done some academic work done that
suggests that it can be exhausting VR at
a certain point that maybe the immersive
games so for example playing Call of
Duty for 18 hours can be exhausting on
an Xbox but in virtual reality's just
too much and I wonder what you think
about that because certainly some
developments are saying that's not going
to be true and people are going to stay
with it if VR is certainly more
immersive one of the things that we're
really focused on is bringing amazing
real-world content into VR
so for example we've been building this
camera called the jump camera that lets
you capture an environment in VR and we
think that's going to open up some
pretty interesting things like taking
you to Machu Picchu or Stonehenge or the
Taj Mahal around the world and there we
think there's something very special
about Vera's ability to transport you
other places and I think that'll be some
of the most compelling and widely
adopted VR content